the battle for donbass will remind you
was second world war
with large operations maneuvers
involvement of thousands of tanks
armored vehicles
planes
artillery uh this will not be a local
operation based on what we see in
russia's preparations to it either you
help us now
and i'm speaking about days not weeks
or
your help will come too late
and
many people will die
many civilians will lose their homes
many villages will be destroyed
exactly because this help
came too late unfortunately to my
deepest regret
bucha is butcher massacre is
just the tip of the iceberg
mari we already see from reports from
marijuana that marijuana is much much
worse
on all accounts
you know weapons are like money they
like they love silence
and uh i will not be in a position to go
into details
but uh
let me put it this way i have no doubts
that ukraine
will have
weapons necessary to fight the question
is the timeline
the damage that is being inflicted on
russia by sanctions now
has
mid and long term implications for
russian economy
but people are dying today
the offensive is unfolding today
and we need steps which will uh
stop russia's war machine today
this is as long as it is not
as this hasn't been done
we cannot speak about efficiency full
efficiency of sanctions yes damage is
inflicted but it's insufficient to stop
russia's war machine